2017-ий запамятається українцям
рекордно спекотним літом.
Температура впродовж тижнів сягала майже
40-градусної позначки.
Це - лише один з наслідків глобальних змін клімату.
Як конкретно вони позначаться на Україні?
Основною загрозою для аграрної сфери, а отже
й харчової сфери є втрати врожаю.
Це випливає з дослідження Національного центру
стратегічних досліджень
"Адаптація до змін клімату в Україні".
Посіви страждають насамперед від засух.
Зменшуються запаси прісної води.
Деяким регіонам, особливо на півдні
та сході України, загрожує опустелювання.
Нищать врожаї також несезонні заморозки,
частіші повені та буревії.
Разом з тим, з підвищенням температур
з"являються можливості отримання додаткового
врожаю - адже теплий період довший.
Більше серцевих нападів через температурні піки улітку,
зате узимку менше смертей через переохолодження.
Хоча в окремі дні зими не виключені ще сильніші морози,
адже річна амлітуда температур загалом збільшується.
Теплі зими означають менші витрати енергії
на побутове опалення.
Водночас потрібно більше струму
на кондиціонери улітку.
Проблеми виникнуть і в гідроенергетиці –
через зміну характеру опадів та річкового стоку.
Основною причиною зміни клімату дослідники
вважають використання викопного палива
і неефективне його споживання.
Але і для самої промисловості екстремальна погода шкідлива.
Гірничодобувні комплекси вразливі до
ерозії ґрунтів і сильних повеней.
Особливо старі будинки не витримують
температурних стрибків та руйнуються.
Житлова інфраструктура буде швидше
ставати непридатною та небезпечною.
Останніми роками стихійних лих
в Україні істотно побільшало,
а подолання їхніх наслідків подорожчало.
За прогнозами, до 2100 року
в Україні потеплішає на 3-4 градуси.
Це у світовому порівнянні надзвичайно багато.
Адже за все ХХ століття  температура
на планеті піднялася менше, ніж на градус,
і вже це призвело до істотних змін і катаклізмів.